Texas continues to take issue with its basic requirement to save women's lives
here's the latest
Texas is suing the department of health and Human Services
over what you might think
is non controversial guidance from the department of health and Human Services
but no so Texas is suing over this guidance
if a physician believes that a pregnant patient comes to the er
with an emergent medical condition
and an abortion would stabilize that patient's condition
then the physician must provide the treatment
oh no no no no says Texas
here's what's going on
there's a federal law from the 90s
called the Emergency Medical Treatment and Active Labor Act: EMTALA
EMTALA basically tells hospitals that look
if a patient comes to your hospital into the er
you need to screen them
and if they have an emergency condition
you either need to transfer them to an appropriate hospital
or you need to stabilize them
so after Dobbs came out
the department of health and Human Services had a sneaking suspicion that red
states were going to start denying pregnant women life saving care
so they sent out this guidance
basically being like
hey red states
like we see your total abortion bans
but we're just trying to remind you
that you have certain federal obligations to save women's lives
so if a woman comes in
and an abortion would stabilize her
when she has an emergency medical condition
you have federal obligations to do that
so Texas sue is over that
because it doesn't want to have to comply with that guidance
it wants its state abortion law to control
because its state
abortion law is much narrower than that guidance
and I'm gonna save you the legal nitty gritty
unless you want it
then tell me in the comments
but basically
the 5th Circuit agreed with Texas
meaning that if a pregnant Texan woman shows up to the emergency room
and an abortion is what she needs to stabilize her care
that is not allowed in Texas
and we're seeing the same litigation out of Idaho
and I just want to make clear how dehumanizing and humiliating it is
to have states debating if and when they have to save our lives
like I feel so gross
disgusted and humiliated reading these pleadings
so at the bare minimum
I just wanna make sure that women understand
and know that this is litigation that is going on
states in the United States
are actively arguing about when they have to save your life
or provide stabilizing care for you
because they don't want to